hogwarts legacy fans it finally happened
you guys we actually
have some legitimate new pieces of
artwork for the game to discuss
information has been
at an absolute trickle on this game
we've been left to
speculating we've been left to digging
for any little piece of information we
can and while i admit
this is not a lot it is certainly more
than we've gotten in a while there's
actually
four new pieces of artwork that we're
gonna talk about here
in today's video people of the internet
retro rack and tour here if we're
meeting for the first time i'm just a
dad who loves games and the stories they
tell we post videos every week here on
youtube and if you're looking for more
hogwarts legacy news theories and
discussion
then make sure you hit that subscribe
button as i mentioned in the opening
today we are talking about
four new pieces of concept art from
an official source you guys this is
actually
legitimately straight from the warner
media ceo he goes by the name of
jasonclar
jasonkalar on twitter and here's what he
says in this tweet guys
great day in salt lake city spending
time with the creators and builders of
the upcoming game hogwarts legacy
concept art on the walls of the studio
will stop you in your tracks it
certainly did for me
very happy to get to be on this team
telling stories in new ways now i want
to caution you guys just a little bit
here this is
concept art so that means it's
conceptual it may not make it into the
final game looking exactly as it does
here in the artwork i'm sure you've seen
this with games before
where you have a piece of concept art
and in the final game it looks slightly
different
but that being said i think it does give
us an indication as to
the overall art style they're going for
the game and a few more creatures that
we
can expect to see so let's dive right
into the first one here which is the
picture of
a baby dragon this is just gorgeous i
would guess
i want to hear what kind of dragon you
guys think this is i think it is a young
swedish short snout definitely has that
silvery blue look and also has the horns
on the top and then kind of on the sides
as well
and then i'm not really sure what's
going on down there in kind of the neck
area i don't know if that's blood or if
they're going for kind of this
iridescent
look there now what i think is very
interesting about this one is that we're
seeing
a young dragon here we see the huge
dragon in the trailer
but this leads me to believe that hey
we're gonna be getting
more than one kind of dragon and also
maybe different
age dragons which is absolutely amazing
now if you're a regular here on the
channel you guys already know that i
think
magical creatures are going to play an
absolutely huge
role in hogwarts legacy i think they're
going to be a key part of the storyline
and seeing these images in the concept
art certainly reinforces that for me
i mean if you just start to think about
all different possible gameplay
scenarios that we could see
around a young dragon i mean maybe it's
similar to what happened with
harry ron and hermione and the
sorcerer's stone with norbert or maybe
we come into contact with this
baby dragon they didn't have to face off
against an even bigger dragon if we
don't treat this dragon the right way we
know we're gonna have choices here in
this game
you don't want to go making mama dragon
angry
but absolutely love this look of the
dragon here i think it's a glorious
piece of concept art
the next one not too much going on here
we see the gryffindor house crest and
then to the right that's kind of faded
we can see slytherin and then also
hufflepuff and we also see some names
that are written on the chart there i
don't know if these are
names of people who work at avalanche
and maybe they
wrote down their names for which house
they're in maybe if some of you know and
recognize those names you could let me
know
or if these are actual characters that
are going to be in game i don't think
they're characters because it looks like
they're all written in different
handwriting so i think these are likely
people that work at avalanche and then
kind of going up to the board and
writing which house they're in now the
appearance of the house crests here
certainly isn't new this has been
featured in a number of places
i think the first place it appeared was
on pottermore but you can tell it is
almost exactly the same style of crest
there
now the next one this is the one by far
that people have been
talking about the most here first of all
let's just talk about the mood
right here the mood that is set when you
take a look
at this concept art the glorious lake in
the background
on this nice warm day and then an adult
grab horn and a baby grab horn here
in this little pin together i mean i
know this is way before hagrid's time
but i'm getting some
hagrid's hut vibes here like i could see
hagrid walking out and kind of tending
to the grab horns
here but again this for me goes back to
what i was talking about earlier with
the dragon and the other video that i
made
the theory that i have about how big
magical creatures are going to be
in this game and one thing that is super
encouraging the fact that we see
different magical creatures with their
young
that i think they're really trying to
create this
living breathing world it's not like we
just see this generic
graph horn every time you go over here
but no
you're going to see a grab horn that is
a a family and i think they're going to
interact with us
in different ways depending on how we go
about the world how we treat the other
characters how we treat the magical
creatures in this world
overall i think more than anything with
this picture is just the
mood that it sets this just sets an
absolute
wonderful mood for i mean just imagine
exploring these grounds right here and
being able to kind of walk up to the pin
of the crab horn
although i really hope we don't have any
twilight princess style
goat herding missions now we're gonna
come back to this
piece of artwork here in a minute
because there's something on this screen
you guys may have caught it already that
we didn't talk about but we're gonna
come back to it don't worry
the fourth image that is shared though
is one of a
garden gnome and it says killer potato
edition so garden gnomes certainly
played a role in the
old harry potter games if you remember
in the chamber of secrets game you
go to the weasleys and you can de-nome
the garden and chuck them
over the fence now the thing about those
gnomes is they are all a generic
standard gnome they all look the same
but here
again going back to this idea that it's
going to be a living
breathing world you're not going to get
the same generic garden gnome every time
you're going to see
various types of garden gnomes in the
game and i don't know about you guys but
this
garden gnome is not a gnome that i would
want to mess with at
all he looks pretty terrifying look at
those teeth man so i said we'd come back
to the other picture and so
we will here we are again on the graph
horn piece
but take your attention off the graph
horn photo for a second
and look at the bottom left corner of
the screen
we see what looks like a jack-o'-lantern
or
a pumpkin here in kind of the bottom
left and then the text right here
m seasonal fall and then turn
around so when it says turn around there
i think what we're seeing on the left
side of the image is maybe just like the
back side of what's on the right i'm not
100 sure about that but
what is most interesting to me about
this is that m
seasonal fall i really don't know what
the m would stand for but the fact that
it says
seasonal fall gets me super
hyped you guys know we did a video on
features we need in hogwarts legacy
one of the things i keep seeing from
fans and one of the things that i
personally really really hope is in the
game
is different seasons and to me i don't
know if we can outright say this is
confirmed because it's again
concept art you got to remember that but
clearly at some point
in the development of this game they
wanted seasons to play
a role and i'll be honest with you guys
i think it's an absolute no-brainer i
think it's almost
guaranteed to happen and to see this on
the concept art just gets me even
more hyped now which piece of concept
art do you guys
enjoy the most what is it that stands
out about them let me know
down in the comments i know you guys are
gonna be super excited to talk about
this
now if you're new here maybe you haven't
seen our other hogwarts legacy videos
i'll throw up that playlist on the right
side of your screen
and if you're in the mood for some old
school harry potter let's plays i'll put
those up here on the left side of the
screen
as always guys thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon